all right alex you talk about the four
types of girls on dating apps what are
the four types of girls oh
the four types of girls okay that video
i did two years ago i believe it was
uh
explicitly dtf so that means a girl who
knows that she wants to [ __ ] and she has
no problem saying it then you got the
implicitly dtf girl who is dtf but she's
not gonna admit it like if you're like
what are you looking for on here she'll
be like oh i don't know just have some
fun uh she won't be direct about it and
with her you can't be super direct then
we have the relationship girl this is
the girl who just wants to date she's
not looking to have sex right away and
then you have the time waster the
infamous time waster this is the girl
who's just looking for validation and
attention she's not gonna meet up with
anyone no matter what huh
huh interesting is it because she's a
narcissist is that what that is
maybe she already has a [ __ ] buddy maybe
she is just looking for instagram
followers maybe she's just likes
validation could be any number of
reasons so blatantly dtf
non-blatantly dtf serious relationship
and then just the time waster yeah i
gotta admit
pretty spot on from what i can tell
ladies feedback what do you got for alex
i agree with all of that i'm i'm like
the middle too
you're the only dtf or you're like like
i will never be straight up i want to
[ __ ] you i've never been that person
i'll be like very subtle if i like if i
like you mickey bands
if you're implicitly
in person at work obviously i go to work
i'm going to [ __ ] you know what i mean
um but what you are not is a time waster
i i don't waste time you don't need it i
i i know nobody get all the time i hate
people without waste my time
i don't like it time
thoughts on these four types of women
well i think you nailed it because hinge
actually just changed uh something that
you can put on your profile that says um
there's like four or five options
looking for long term open to short term
looking for short term open to long term
looking for long term looking for short
term and like just what uh app does this
so they're just like look that you can
choose everything and like that i really
appreciate i think hinge is the best
because you can i can tell if a guy has
kids
i mean i can try he can put it if he
wants but lately i've been meeting a lot
of married guys who don't reveal that
until later in the game but they can
write that on there a lot of cheaters on
hinge
but um i think it's find you
[ __ ] it's cool to just be like
hey this is what i'm looking for so a
guy can just swipe left if he's not
but i don't feel like they will i feel
like they'll still try i feel like hinge
needs to pay you for this plug right
pay up this episode is brought to you by
hinge
if you're dtf we're down to help you out
here all right so i've been permanently
banned from all the dating apps why is
that
all the videos i made probably just go
on
they went and found your they never sent
me an email but it's like whenever i
recreate an account just gets instantly
banned it's interesting i think i've
made like too many videos breaking their
terms of service oh i wouldn't what are
you in terms of service like i'm sure
you can't take screenshots from the app
put it on your youtube channel yeah
that's probably awesome that's frowned
upon alex yeah i'm for sure but alex you
knew that going in homie come on yeah i
made my piece for that
exactly you're not like why are they
doing this so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]